we're gonna go ahead and get situated
this is the finance program and we
always like to see new faces
when you come to wall street's financial
literacy class you're gonna see people
with tattoos and dreads and just people
you normally wouldn't expect to see
learning finance
you're going to see people of all
different backgrounds looking for hope
he makes it universal
[Music]
if i tell you i'll give you the 50 bucks
but i want you to pay me back fifty
dollars in interest what you're gonna
say
say no you gonna say what no and why you
gonna say no they called me wall street
because i teach all the financial
classes here at san quentin and i've
been teaching financial education for
about 10 years now
i am in prison for participating in a
robbery murder
and i was sentenced to 54 years of life
in prison
for that crime and i've been
incarcerated now for 22 years
these are the stocks that i picked
mastercard i got 89 they're at 200. wall
street came to prison illiterate
he doesn't have a college education to
this day he only has a ged and yet this
guy is successfully trading from prison
my cellie who had come from juvenile
hall with me he would read the sports
page to me like man go get it and i'll
read it i grabbed the paper and i was
like i got it when i turned around an
older guy said hey man you play the
stock market and i've realized that i
picked up the business section instead
of the sports page i was like ah man
and i asked him what the stock market
was and he told me he said that's the
place where white folks keep all their
money and that's when i really first
discovered the stock market
so i started teaching myself how to read
family
friends on the outside opened up online
brokers accounts and i basically told
them what to buy and when to buy one to
sell and i mean that was essentially
because it was really just that easy
this is a finance program
but i don't teach about finance
i teach financial
empowerment emotional
literacy
that's what i teach
so i think financial education is
important for incarcerated people
given that the crimes that are committed
are financially motivated and driven
when i learned about financial education
myself i thought that would be something
that other men in my same situation
could benefit from
and so now the program teaches
incarcerated men how to better manage
their emotions and relations to their
financial standing so you gotta weigh
your strategies when you're talking
about giving yourself room to start
saving money
when you're traumatized you do a lot of
things you don't know why you're doing
them and that happens with finance too
i suffered a lot of trauma in my life
and my trauma like culminated in me
murdering a man
so while this is very important to me to
because i do need to
manage my money and manage my life
what's most important is that i'm
managing my emotional responsibilities
because the last time i didn't do that a
man lost his life
i don't think you can have full
rehabilitation without financial
education
i can make amends for the crimes that
i've done i can even stop doing the
things that i've done but i think
for people who were criminals
when you empower those people and they
know that they don't have to commit
crime like i did when i learned how to
have to commit crime it was like wow
like i can really make something in my
life and i don't have to be a criminal
[Music]
[Music]
you